Kathy, I hope this isn't too personal of a question,...
...but are you dating anyone at the moment?
Am I dating anyone? Well, no, not really. Why?
Just curious.
I was just wondering about the whole dating scene here in America.
Well, do men usually ask women out first?
They generally do. What's up Changmin?
Have you met someone special lately?
Well, to tell you the truth, there's a girl that I'm interested in.
Can you give me some advice about love?
Maybe I can give you some advice.
Go on. So, did you ask her out?
No, not yet. I don't know what she thinks of me.
Changmin, I think you should be honest with yourself.
The best thing is to be yourself.
Thanks. I really appreciate  your advice.